President Trump still getting used to
saying that it's been seven months or
something right six months I still it's
still strange it yes he's won a contest
yeah
president Trump gave a big speech last
night in Afghanistan and if anyone saw
that yeah in his speech on Afghanistan
last night President Trump said attack
we will yeah
then Trump introduced his new military
strategist general mad dog Yoda attack
we will just destroy we must strange now
before announcing his decision on
Afghanistan President Trump was said to
have made a rigorous that's what his
people are saying rigorous review of the
issue yes Trump said I must have read at
least four tweets about it and then I
was I was ready to go he almost read the
tweets all the way through yeah yeah
yeah he got most of the way through him
he had to scroll a whole full time yeah
yeah and then it was all up here a lot
of protesters at a rally today in
Phoenix attended by President Trump and
vice president pence yeah a lot of
protesters there who's got awkward when
it turned out that the impeach Trump
chance for being led by Mike Pence
okay
that's the face pen like Trump and boots
drop Oh Mark Wahlberg
that's right Mark Wahlberg has been
named 2017 s highest-paid male actor
yeah today Mark said I don't know why
either okay Yuri this is gonna get your
attention I tell you man there's a new
beer I'm I'm not making this up new beer
coming out that can wear this guy will
get you your drink sir don't worry
people come here to make bird noises and
for a drink there's a new beer coming
out that contains marijuana yeah
unfortunately the inventor cannot for
the life of him remember how he made it
made one that's good no idea how that
happened
India India has outlawed its long-long
practice of instant divorce used to be
oh yeah they're outlawing instant
divorce in India however India will
still continue to offer its popular Cool
Ranch divorce
hey we were on the line about that one
but it just made me happy I wanted to do
it speaking of food our beats in the
news Arby's is celebrating the game of
thrones season finale by offering its
customers a giant turkey leg yeah yeah
it's all part of their game of Thrones
tie-in diarrhea is coming I don't
understand how this goes with what I
just said at all I mean I have theories
but I'd rather not yeah yeah
you